my name is Charlotte Wickham and I'm a
developer educator on the CTO team at
posit it's been a little over a year
since we introduced CTO and the team has
been working really hard on some new
features I know you can get so caught up
actually working with your tools that
it's hard to keep up with the changes in
those tools so think about this as your
annual holiday letter from a formed but
far away friend updating you on the
highlights of the Year I'll focus on the
things that I think are most useful to
you as a author of Cotto documents
grouped into three categories content
these are things you can add to any
Cotto document that enhance or add
content to that
document projects a couple of features
that make it easier to work with
collections of Cotto documents and tools
these are enhancements to the tools you
might use to author quoto documents
before we jump in let me give you a
little context on quto
versions quto 1.0 was the version when
CTO was released last year CTO 1.1 and
1.2 were released before the end of the
year and Cordo 1.3 was released in April
this year
2023 Cordo 1.3 is the current release
that means it's the one you'll find when
you head to our downloads page on c.org
and it's the version that the dou
umentation describes we do release
updates to the current release but those
updates are somewhat infrequent some of
the features I'll describe today are
coming in Cordo
1.4 and if you want to try them out
you'll need to download what we call the
pre-release the pre-release is a
snapshot of the main branch of our get
repo and as such it's updated really
frequently so if you're going to sit
down and do something with the
pre-release you want to make sure you
grab the latest version from c.org if
you aren't sure which version of CTO you
have you can use the version option to
CTO on the command line okay let's jump
into some new content
features the first feature I want to
show you is the embed short code imagine
you've got a Cordo document and you've
imported some data done some processing
done some exploration and you've landed
at a visualization that you really want
to include in another
document I'll call this document with
all the code that gets to the
visualization The Source document what
you want to end up with is another
document I'll call it the destination
with just this visualization in
it the embed short code lets you do that
with one line let's
see here's that Source document and the
code chunk that generates the
visualization we'll need a way to
identify the s so let's add a label I'll
call it fig Das
scatter then in the destination document
I'll use the short code the embed short
code requires a path to the source file
followed by a sell
identifier that's
it the sell options Come From the Source
document so if you want to add a caption
you'll need to do that in the source
document when rendered the output from
that Source document will be included in
the destination document in HTML formats
you also get a link back to a rendered
version of that Source document the
embed short coat was introduced in quto
1.3 but only when the source was a
Jupiter notebook in quto 1.4 you'll be
able to do embeds from qmd documents
too quto 1.4 is bringing some big
changes to cross references in
particular you'll be able to make almost
anything a cross referenceable element
all the current cross reference syntax
will still work but CTO 1.4 adds some
new syntax that's more
flexible to define a cross referenceable
element you'll need to create a div with
an ID that has a prefix that CTO
recognizes as a cross
reference so for instance here the
triple colons indicate the div followed
by an ID starting with fig that lets
Cotto know that this is a figure cross
reference then comes the content for
this element and then the final line
will be interpreted as the
caption then I can refer back to this
element using the usual syntax an at
symbol followed by the ID of the
element when rendered CTO adds figure
along with a counter and generates the
text and Link wherever I refer back to
this
element with this new syntax I can put
almost anything inside this div I could
put a code cell inside and call it a
figure or I could put an image inside
and by changing the prefix to TBL call
it a
table the other new thing you'll be able
to do is Define custom types of cross
reference in your
yaml the key names here are still a work
in progress but essentially you decide
what the prefix will be that will
identify this as a cross reference in
the div ID
and the labels used in the caption and
for the in text
references here I'm defining one that
will represent
diagrams then you can switch to this new
type of cross reference and now you have
control over the text used to represent
this
reference each type of cross reference
maintains its own counter so defining a
new type of cross reference also gives
you a way to restart a
counter
this next feature is specific to the
Jupiter engine and it adds a feature
that nitar users have had for a long
time an easy way to get computed values
in line so for example imagine you had a
document with a python code cell that
defined the variable
radius and what you want in your output
is a sentence that refers to the value
in that
variable it used to be that You' need a
code cell and inside that code cell you
would have to generate the markdown for
that entire sentence and then feed it
into the markdown
function quto 1.4 introduces a new
syntax for inline execution single back
ticks followed by Python and curly
braces followed by the code to be
executed in this case we're just
grabbing the variable
itself or if you happen to use the Julia
Jupiter kernel you could swap this out
for a Julia example as well
the final content features I want to
talk about are really useful if you tend
to write about code and you want to add
additional context for your
readers for example imagine seeing this
code in a rendered document it happens
to be yaml and it was produced with this
markdown in its source I think the first
piece of context people need when
they're looking at code is where this
code
is in this case this is code you'd find
in theore quo. yaml file in a quto
project you can add that by adding the
file name attribute to the code cell
which adds a header to the code cell in
the rendered
output here the code lives in an actual
file but the file name attribute doesn't
have to be a file name for instance you
might say this code is written in the
terminal or this code is written on the
r
console
the other feature for adding context to
code is code annotation code annotation
lets you add comments about specific
lines of code for HTML output I really
like the hover setting Where The
annotation is only revealed on Hover so
that it doesn't distract from the
code adding code annotation is a matter
of adding specially formatted comments
to the code itself along with an ordered
list directly following the
code
now switching to
projects because they involve many files
cord projects can sometimes be a little
bit more complicated to get
started create is a Cotto command
introduced in 1.2 that makes it really
easy to produce a minimal working
project here I am on the terminal
running CTO
create this then runs through an
interactive prompt where I can select I
want to create a project of type website
in the directory test- website Cotto
then creates that directory and
populates it with a minimal working set
of
files this works in any terminal but
because I use the r Studio terminal CTO
will create an R Studio project file and
open up that project for me then I might
build it just to see what I've got I
love using the interactive prompt but
you can also specify all those options
as part of the command
this is a really handy way to build
small reproducible examples of projects
or to get started with a project type
that's new to
you the other project feature I want to
show you are what's called project
profiles imagine you've got a project
where you need variations of basically
the same content but for different
audiences or different
venues so for example maybe you want a
version of a report to share with it
external stakeholders and another
version for internal use that has a
little bit more
detail your project might start like
this a quo file report. qmd where I've
just got a placeholder for some content
that everyone might
see andore quo. yaml with some project
level information like the project title
and a location for the rendered output
to go in this case a folder called
external so if I was to render this
project I'd get this report. HTML in the
folder
external this represents rendering
without a profile activated to add a
profile you add another Cotto
configuration file but with an extra
suffix I'm going to call minecore C-
internal. yo to activate the profile you
can add the profile option to the render
command
so here I'm running quto render with
profile set to
internal when activated the options in
the profile configuration file are
merged with those in the default
configuration file I'm going to add a
different output directory to my
internal
profile let me say
internal then when I render with this
profile activated I get this report.
HTML in the internal
folder not very exciting yet but I can
use this profile to start making changes
that distinguish the internal output
from my default
output so just to visually make a
distinction I could add a theme to my
internal
profile in addition to having a profile
apply different options you can also use
it to control
content let's take another look at
report. qmd I'm going to add some
content that I want only visible in the
inter internal
report to have it show up only when the
internal profile is activated I can put
it inside a div and add the content
visible class with the wi profile
attribute set to
internal now if I render both with and
without the internal profile activated I
get these two versions report. HTML in
the external folder has only one section
and report. HTML in the internal folder
has
two the biggest changes in authoring
tools are two out extensions for visual
studio code and Jupiter lab the visual
studio code extension now has a visual
editor just like our studio when you
enter the visual editor you get a what
you see is what you get editing
experience for your quto documents for
example rather than seeing markdown
syntax you see formatted text text one
of the nicest features of the visual
editor is the insert anything tool
simply type a forward slash and you'll
get a drop down of all the content types
you might
insert a nice example is insert table
and if you only need one reason to use
the visual editor it should be for
editing tables without having to worry
about markdown
syntax another nice feature in the
visual studio code extension is
completion for citations and cross
references simply type the at symbol and
you'll see completions for cross
referenceable items like figures or
tables or sections as well as citations
from your bibliography
file there is now also a Jupiter lab
quto extension this extension interprets
the quto markdown in your file and gives
you a more realistic preview of that
document from within the
editor that that's it for the new
features I wanted to show you there are
a couple of other big features coming in
quto 1.4 that I haven't talked about
because you can hear about them in other
posit conf talks that's manuscript
projects for scholarly writing and
typist support as an alternative to
latch for PDF
output you might be wondering how you
can keep up with changes to quto the
most definitive list for the changes in
each quto release is the change log and
you can find that on the download page
on koto.org you can also find them in
the news folder on our GitHub
repo we also like to blog about some of
the highlights of each release so you
might want to follow the Cotto blog as
well the best place to ask questions
about New or Old features is on the
discussion board on our GitHub repo and
if there's something new in Cotto you'd
like to see there's a feature request
category there too
thanks for listening and I hope you've
seen something that you're eager to try
[Applause]
out hello welcome back so we got
Charlotte live hello we can see you
hello can you hear me too yes we can
loud and clear lovely um you of as a
good pres presenter I already haded off
one of the course questions uh which was
going to be it's lovely to get letters
but what if you don't want to wait until
next year's conference but you know
you've been there um a fact question
when is quarter 1.4 going to be
released good question the word is fall
of this year so we're already in Fall I
I would expect we're still sort of doing
some active development there'll be a
bit of a cooling off period after to
that I would expect it before Christmas
just that sounds like a lovely Christmas
present and we I see JJ in the audience
giving a thumbs up so Christmas people
going to be good um we got another
one uh oh okay Charlotte why is the
Syntax for inline code for Python and
Julia slightly different than
R that's a good question um and somebody
more knowled then I will know exactly
why but as far as I know it's sort of a
limitation of the the Jupiter
engine um and I know it can be a little
bit jarring because if you're used to R
you're used to just the back tick and
then a sort of bare letter r uh the good
news is that we're actually also
including that new style syntax uh for R
for the Knitter engine so that for
instance if you're teaching this there
sort of only one syntax you'll need to
teach so starting in qu 1.4 you'll also
be able to Enit a say single backtick
and then R in those curly braces um that
same syntax will work for
you that's really fun to watch Charlotte
explain and cols go like yes yes yes yes
yes is excellent um multicolumn
documents specifically multicolumn PDFs
is that possible in
quarter yeah totally possible that's
possible now um it is one of the areas
where uh our documentation is perhaps a
little bit hard to find um but you want
to hunt around on the website for uh the
layout uh attribute uh most of our
examples show that with HTML so it's
it's really easy to sort of put elements
in uh columns with that but that also
works in PDF um that will that's
generally something you might do on an
element kind of basis like you've got
you know a couple of figures and a table
that you want to lay out in multiple
columns um you can also of course use
any of the latch or coming soon typist
uh ways of of doing that at a document
level um it's just going to require a
little bit more work uh on the uh well
it's it's something you're more likely
to have to do inside a template or or in
the yl as opposed to actually in your
content okay um now you can rattle off
support for other languages if there
is that is another question uh yeah so
the S of the the the big things
obviously are Python and also observable
JS um but anything that has a Jupiter
kernel any language that has a Jupiter
kernel you can
use okay so I'll leave it up to you if
your favorite language you've got to
identify if your favorite language has a
Jupiter kernel and if it does you can
use cter all right um good doing sort of
a bit of an Outlook as my last question
um what are new features that you would
like to develop in the next year or two
for
quarter oh that's a good question um and
I
uh I mostly am working on the
documentation side of things and the uh
and getting people on board to Cordo
side of thing so I most of the things I
want to do aren't necessarily building
new features in Cordo but making sure
people um can find the features they're
looking for uh and that we're helping
onboard people onto
um I personally think we could do some
pretty big improvements to our c.org
website um so you know let me know if
you've also got ideas about that uh I
think that's something that you'll see
coming soon all right the Placer GI herb
issues and discussions for this right to
give
feedback yes yes yes yes defitely yeah
and that's actually something I should
point out that um it's a little
confusing because everything happens on
C- CLI repo but you are most welcome to
ask questions there about the website
about documentation anything that goes a
little bit beyond the actual command
line interface itself okay thank you
very much so let's give a hand up for
[Applause]
Charlotte